the king's
advisor arbegla is watching all of this
discourse between you the king and the
bird and he's trying to feel a little
bit jealous because he's supposed to be
the wise man in the kingdom the king's
closest advisor so he steps in and says
okay if you and this bird are so smart
how about you tackle the riddle of the
fruit prices and the king says yes that
is something that we haven't been able
to figure out the fruit prices our bagla
tell them the riddle of the fruit prices
and so our bagless says well
we've we've want to keep track of how
much our fruit costs but we forgot to
actually log how much it cost when we
went to the market but we know how much
in total we spent we know how much we
got we know that one week ago when we
went to the fruit market we bought two
two pounds
of apples
we brought two pounds of apples and one
pound of bananas
one pound i guess i can one pound
of bananas
bananas and the total cost that time was
three dollars so there was a three
dollars
three dollars in total cost and then we
went the time before that
when we went the time before that we
bought six pounds of bananas six or six
pounds of apples i should say
six pounds of apples and three pounds
three pounds of bananas
bananas
and
the total cost at that point was 15
so what is the cost of apples and
bananas so you look at the bird the bird
looks at you the the bird whispers into
the king's ear and the king says well
the bird says well just start defining
some variables here so we can express
this thing algebraically so you go about
doing that what we want to figure out is
the cost of apples and the cost of
bananas per pound
so we set some variables so let's let a
equal the cost
cost of apples
apples per pound
per pound
and let's let b
equal the cost
of bananas
bananas
bananas per pound so how could we
interpret this this first information
right over here two pounds of apples and
a pound of bananas cost three dollars
well how much are the apples going to
cost well it's going to cost two
two pounds times the cost per pound
times a
that's going to be the total cost of the
apples in this scenario and what's the
total cost of the bananas what's one
pound times the cost per pound
so
you're just going to have b that's going
to be the total cost of the bananas
because we know we bought one pound so
the total cost of the apples and bananas
are going to be 2a plus b
and we know what that total cost is it
is
it is three dollars now let's do the
same thing for the other time that we
went to the market
six pounds of apples the total cost is
going to be six pounds
times a dollars per pound and the total
cost of bananas is going to be well we
bought three pounds of bananas
and the cost per pound is b
and so the total cost of the apples and
bananas this scenario is going to be
equal to
15
is going to be equal to 15 dollars so
let's think about how we might want to
solve it we could use elimination we
could use substitution whatever we want
we could even do it graphically let's
let's try it first with elimination so
the first thing i might want to do
is maybe i want to eliminate let's say i
want to eliminate the a variable right
over here so i have 2a over here i have
6a over here so if i multiply this
entire white equation by negative 3
then this 2a would become a negative 6a
and then it might be able to cancel out
with that so let me do that let me
multiply this entire equation the entire
equation times negative three
times negative three
so negative three times two a is
negative six a
negative three times b is negative three
b
and then negative 3 times 3 is negative
9
is negative 9. and now we can
essentially add the two equations or add
the left side of this equation to the
left side of that and the right side of
this equation to the right side of that
we're essentially adding the same thing
to both sides of the screen equation
because we know that this is equal to
that so let's do that
let's do it so on the left hand side 6a
and 6a cancel out
but something else interesting happens
the 3b and the 3b cancels out as well so
we're just left with zero
on the left hand side
and on the right hand side what do we
have 15 minus 9 is equal to 6.
so we get this bizarre statement all of
our variables have gone away and we're
left with this bizarre nonsensical
statement that 0
is equal to 6 which we know which we
know is definitely not the case so
what's going on over here what's going
on
and then you you you say what's going on
and you look at the bird because the
bird seems to be the most knowledgeable
person in the room or at least the most
knowledgeable
vertebrate in the room and so the bird
whispers into the king's ear and the
king says
well
he he says that there's there's no
solution and you should at least try to
graph it to see why and so you say well
the bird seems to know what he's talking
about so let me attempt to graph these
two equations and see what's going on
and so what i'm what you do is you take
each of the equation and you like when
you graph it you like to put it in kind
of the y-intercept form or
slope-intercept form and so you do that
so you say well let me solve both of
these for b so if you want to solve this
first equation for b you just subtract
2a from both sides if you subtract 2a
from both sides of this first equation
you get b
is equal to negative 2a
plus 3. now let's solve this second
equation for b
so the first thing you might want to do
is subtract 6a from both sides so you
would get
you would get i'll do it right over let
me do it right over here you would get
3b
3b is equal to negative 6a
plus 15
and then you can divide both sides by 3
you get b is equal to negative 2a
plus
plus 5. so the second equation let me
revert back to that other shade of green
is b
is equal to negative two a
plus five and we haven't even graphed it
yet but it looks like something
interesting is going on
they both have the exact same slope when
you solve in terms when you solve for b
but they seem to have different i guess
you could call them b intercepts let's
graph it to actually see what's going on
so let me get draw some axes over here
so that is my let's call that my b axis
and then this could be my a axis
and this first equation has a b
intercept of positive three so let's see
one two three four five the first one
has a b intercept of positive three
and it has a slope of negative two so
you go down or you go to the right one
you go down two
go to the right one you go down two so
the line looks something like this
i'm trying my best to draw it straight
so it looks
it looks something
something like that and now let's draw
this green one
this green one our b intercept is five
so it's right over here but we have the
exact same slope a slope of negative two
so it looks it looks something
something
like
that right over there and you
immediately see now that the bird was
right there is no solution because these
two constraints represent la or can be
represented by lines that don't
intersect
so the lines don't
don't intersect
intersect
they don't intersect and so the bird is
right there's no solution there's no x
and y that can make this statement equal
true or that can make zero equals six
there is no possible there is no overlap
between these two things
and so something gets into your brain
you realize that arbeigla is trying to
stump you and you say arbeigla you have
given me inconsistent information this
is an inconsistent system of equations
in
inconsistent which happens to be the
word that is sometimes used to refer to
a system that has no solutions where the
lines do not intersect and therefore
this information is incorrect we cannot
assume that the apple or banana either
you are lying which is possible or you
accounted for it wrong or maybe the
prices of apples and bananas actually
changed between the two visits to the
market at which point the bird whispered
into the king's ear and says oh this
this character isn't so bad at this at
this algebra stuff